hello dear listener
I have some thoughts I'd like to share
about the controversy surrounding
AI art people have many opinions about
artificial intelligence and whether
us deploying
the algorithms that govern these AI
platforms to create something original
whether that counts as art or whether
it's a kind of cheat code or amputation
of our creative capacity is the
offloading of an aspect of the engine of
creation is the offloading of that
engine of creation to Silicon
a kind of unfair advantage that somehow
invalidates the creative impulse that is
the question right the idea is well now
you don't need craft you don't need the
skills the years of Labor of an
illustrator you know developing his
talent refining his ability to shrink
the lag time between what he imagines
and what he creates so there's a sort of
protestant work ethic belief about art
born creative but you've got to you've
got to earn the right to be an artist
these AI algorithms miraculous as they
are they they
are
forces of massive disruption because
they have a different argument to make
I can't make an AI program in fact the
people that learn computer programming
to make the AI programs that are now
governing the algorithms behind AI art
they are a kind of Genius that eludes
meat nonetheless those algorithms now
permit the
the exercising of a new kind of coupling
between biological and unbiological
props and scaffoldings Jason's
imagination Jason's word play can now be
made manifest visually in the world as I
speak so it becomes words become
incantations
AI art unleashes a new marriage a new
coupling of biological and digital
technology whereby as I imagine so it
becomes technology that shrinks the lag
time between my dreams and their
instantiation you might even say the
imagination is summoning its own
literalization you might even say that
empowered by these Technologies of AI
algorithms we are all becoming finally
imagineers
we are bound in we are limited only by
our dreams the deeper we dream the
deeper our art the the the the the
vaster our imaginative yearnings the the
the the the the more Sublime the
universe is they will give rise to
it's like we all free the brave Reckless
gods that live inside of us it's like
we're all
creators of Pandora
we become like James Cameron rendering
world into being like a dream it's a
psychedelic fever dream in fact
a kind of
digitalization of our inner life a kind
of the mind turning itself inside out
a kind of
exteriorization of our universe
a kind of stepping out of ourselves
and becoming something more as I imagine
so it becomes and this is the very
essence of magic
in a cyborgian
way
We are Becoming as Gods digital Gods a
marriage of biology and Technology
friends I am
convinced of this hypothesis I am
reminded of Kevin Kelly's notion of how
impoverished the world would have been
without the technology of the musical
instrument in time for Beethoven or the
technology of the oil painting in time
for Van Gogh no doubt some may see it
as a as a cheating as a shortcut that we
can type a few words and turn them into
some phantasmagornic image but imagine
what the right words can give rise to
the new engineer is the prompt engineer
you know
[Music]
Terence McKenna he said the world
the world is made of words and if you
know the words the world is made of you
can make of it whatever you wish
first there was the word and the Word
was God like I truly believe that the
full flourishing of these technological
couplings
at their very best will turn all of us
into the central character in the
never-ending story
as we imagine so it becomes
this is the very essence
[Music]